four minutes remain in the tournament of
power and we are down to the final five
fighters some have made huge impacts
while others have been picking their
moments but questions like who has had
the most eliminations who's helped their
team the most and who is in the best
position to win are still kind of
unanswered I hope to help answer those
today
I'll be breaking down each character's
performance talking about their
highlights who they've eliminated and
how well they seem to be helping their
teams so without further ado let's dive
right into this leaderboard with our
first fighter right off the bat as the
tournament began Vegeta along with Goku
Frieza
and the two androids decided to abandon
the strategy of stick together and one
of the writers intended for it to pan
out the way it did are not every
character who stuck to the game plan
ended up being eliminated before those
five fighters who bailed on the gameplan
early regardless Vegeta not only managed
to survive every fight he found himself
in but by and large he thrived without
assistance he managed to eliminate topo
hyssop aragón Oh hop dr. Rocha magetta
and prompt bringing his elimination
count to seven now while vigía is
naturally a singles competitor he hasn't
been opposed to lending a hand here and
there to his teammates racking up
eliminations against Bergamo basil
lavender and the four-way fusion of anna
lhasa now because anna lhasa is made up
of four individual fighters he counts as
for individual eliminations also keeping
that in mind this brings Vegeta's total
elimination count to 14 Vegeta's most
noteworthy plays the tournament have
been his protection of Goku while he was
charging the spirit bomb his elimination
of Topo and his ability to stand
toe-to-toe with Goku as he takes on
Geron however at this point Vegeta
stamina is very low and his body has
received significant damage after his
fight with Topa with that said while I
don't expect him to win he has more than
contributed in this tournament
definitely more than our next competitor
anyway
Jaron has spent the majority of this
tournament posturing watching meditating
and floating
I thought flying of any kind was negated
unless you had wings or something but I
digress
while Universal Evans final fighter
hasn't been a dominating presence on the
scoreboard he has been a monster in the
tournament as a whole to help put this
in perspective if Hughes imasu was your
backyard wall for instance then Jaron is
wall Maria from attack on Titan or at
least that's what it feels like when he
literally stairs a final flash away
[Applause]
jaren only has two eliminations to his
name with no team eliminations to speak
of and while being this late in the
tournament with so few eliminations is
strange to see you'll notice that one of
those two eliminations is hit who was a
fan favorite to go the distance early on
in the tournament so at least that's
something
Judeans highlights from the tournament
so far are how easily he dismantled
ultra instinct Goku for the first time
and how he dealt with Goku and Vegeta
simultaneously something few characters
in fiction could say that they could
muster and here's a fun fact
topo dispo and the rest of universe 11
did not eliminate a single person making
Jared the only reason why they are on
the scoreboard in the first place and
finally Geron enters the final four
minutes of the tournament of power with
virtually no damage sustained this man
has thoroughly impressed me when he was
announced as a participant early on I
thought that this was pure fanservice
and while that is still true
he has been hugely entertaining in this
arc throughout effortlessly cool
implementing strategy and picking his
moments Android 17 has found himself in
the final 5 amidst some of the most
terrifying ly powerful individuals
within the multiverse and to get there
he eliminated his fair share of fighters
- taking out Dom on soo Sanka and Vic al
on his own bringing his solo elimination
count to four and with the help of
others he eliminated vieira
and he led the charge on an eel as a--
bringing his total eliminations in the
tournament of power tonight and I think
17 has brought viewers some of the most
joyous moments to his tournament
highlights include eliminating two of
the three Sailor Scouts while playing a
key role in helping Android 18 eliminate
the beloved character rip ryan he's
leading the charge in the elimination of
play Laza
and finally saving Frieza from
elimination a move that could
potentially if things go the way I think
they'll go save universe 7 from
destruction
as it stands thanks to his Android body
17 has unlimited stamina with minor
damage on his body unlike our net
despite Frieza being out of commission
right now he has been to tell you the
truth the only reason I have been
excited while watching this tournament
introduced as a substitute for majin buu
I was beyond excited at the thought of
having Frieza work alongside the main
cast to war as a common goal his
wildcard nature adds a layer of nuance
of the tournament making it more
difficult to figure out how it will end
or at the very least enabling us to
suspend our disbelief more easily and
it's not like he has been sitting on his
hands either Frieza has on his own
eliminated five fighters and a lot of
those could have been tricky opponents
had Frieza not dealt with them when he
did
they include Rosella murikkum frost Kaba
and jimes as part of a team Frieza aided
in the elimination of both dispo and an
eel Aza eliminations that we look at
them all stacked together are not too
shabby at all bringing his total
elimination count as of episode one
hundred and twenty six to ten most of
freezes highlights pretty much go hand
in hand with his eliminations they
include his double cross of frost
resulting in his elimination his
knocking out of Gohan and dispo his
donation of energy to Goku and his
tenacious fight with topo as god of
destruction due to unfortunate
circumstances
freezes body is battered and is
currently very low on stamina last and
almost inevitably not least we have Goku
as the main character he has a certain
amount of plot armor so naturally many
of us fully expected Goku to be here and
again unsurprisingly Goku has at the
moment the most eliminations out of
everyone he has so low eliminated kefla
fusion of cauliflower kale mink Chapel
comfrey Ruben rah
czar Bhutto and Zuerlein bringing his
total solo eliminations to 8 and when
you factor in the team eliminations of
Bergamo basil lavender and annie lhasa
goku currently stands with a total of 15
eliminations to his name
Goku's highlights during the tournament
include his unlocking of ultra instinct
as well as his first fight with Joran
his battle with kefla and that amazing
kamehameha grind thing oh and of course
his teamwork with Vegeta among other
ventures I'm sure as it stands Goku is
low on stamina while having sustained a
decent amount of physical damage also
though not as much as Vegeta and so as
of episode 126 this is what the
standings currently look like
this arc is written less like a
tournament and more like universe sevens
journey to reach universe 11 who sort of
act like the final bosses so to speak
for this reason universes two three four
nine ten and eleven combined have
eliminated only eight people in total
universe six aka the only other universe
with characters we are familiar with has
eliminated twelve and universe seven has
eliminated fifty to sixty five percent
of the entrance to help better put this
in perspective
Kroon has three times more eliminations
to his name then this guy
the goal of this tournament has always
been cheering and how universe seven aka
Goku will overcome him Geron may only
have two eliminations to his name but
one of them was hit a character that
from this timeline was the only non god
character to challenge Goku so in
Durin's case its quality over quantity
Juran's word elimination off hit means
much more than whoever comma eliminated
now I'm not saying universe 7 as a whole
is the focus it's even more specific
than that it's clear the tournament was
designed to get to this point Vegeta
Goku Frieza and 17 have clear character
traits carved out for themselves Goku is
tenacious Vegeta is selfless and
aggressive Frieza is ruthless and
willing to do anything to win and
Android 17 is majorly resourceful these
traits have been established throughout
the tournament even characters like go
on have largely been used to establish
all their characters which results in
him getting very little single
eliminations - compared to his 7 team
eliminations Vegeta overcame topo which
was arguably his best character moment
in the series someone like Vegeta who
was once a selfish Prince is now a
selfless father husband and friend topos
willingness to abandon justice to
embrace destruction is juxtaposed to
Vegeta and how his character has changed
over time battling with similar demons
Vegeta now knows where his true values
lie ax as an individual verbally
rejecting that ideology saying screw
that to topo and that's what this arcs
main goal has been really creating
signature character moments for our
favor characters with only five fighters
remaining in the tournament of power and
Juran being the last one for universe 7
to overcome things are only going to get
better who do you think will win the
tournament of power did I miss anything
or glanced over something let me know
down below don't forget to leave a like
if you enjoyed this video and feel free
to subscribe for more Dragon Ball
content but that'll do it for this week
I've been totally not mark thank you so
much for watching